the largest US organization fighting
sexual violence estimates that more than
800 Americans are victimized every day
that works out to one sexual assault get
this every 98 seconds this is one of
America's most underreported crimes
Jericka Duncan asks sexual assault
survivors at the cleveland rape crisis
center how they handled the recent
claims of sexual misconduct in hollywood
politics and the media why is it so
important to talk to people like you
everyday americans who have been
sexually assaulted harassed considering
where we are right now in this moment
because at the end of the day we're all
human beings and i think that it it
doesn't matter what your position or
status is in life
my first experience is being sexually
violated it goes back at the age of five
I was molested by my mother's boyfriend
I was abused by a family member I was
raped by a co-worker at my old job I was
sexually assaulted five and a half years
ago by a co-worker of my husband I'm a
survivor of childhood sexual abuse and
rape I was abused by a man who lived in
my neighborhood I'm grateful for people
starting to speak up and speak out
sometimes only it takes to hear from one
person you know and none of us are like
TV personalities so that's a beautiful
thing the way people are responding to
the celebrities and people who have a
name
I really wish Society we respond to our
everyday survivors the same way they had
some position of power and sexual
assault and abuse and rape is really
about the power and the control not the
sex and we're not going to keep pushing
it under the rug or throwing a carpet
over it or turning a blind eye because
you have a title I think we need to just
make sure that we give a voice to all
survivors and that's what I'm really
excited and looking at who's here with
us today because I think so many times
that we think we're alone but we're not
alone
we should note those are some brave
survivors for speaking out last year
more than 36,000 people turned to the
cleveland rape crisis center for help